OETTINGER AND LET'S SAVE
AS THAT PUCK PUT ON NET.
A SCRAMBLE FORER.HE RIGHT SKATE
ABLE TO GET ACROSS AND AHO
THOUGHT HE HAD AN EMPTY MAKE TH.
THE PUCK ISHIS TEAM.
BOB: HERE'S KLINGBERG.
BACKHANDER TOSS LINE.
PUTS ON THE BRAKES.
CENTERS ONE.
HE'S ABL HAVING
A LITTLE CONVERSATION ABOUT IT.
BOB:E!
JAMIE BENN THREW IT ONFENDER.
BUT TERRIFIC ENTRY THERE BY
A DROP ON THE DOORSTEP.
THE REBOUND.
INTERCEPTED BY BRBR SKJEI WHO KE
PLAY ALIVE AND THEN MAKES THE
PLAYALL.
AHO KEEPS IT ALIVE.
WRISTER! THE CANES HAVE THE TO L
THE NOT ABLE TO HELP OUT
AND THAT IS A GRADE A
AND AND PASS!
AND HE DEFLECTS IT GOING.
ROBERTSON AND AS I MENTIONED
HERERE
AND IS ITTHE PUCK CHANGEGE
ANDREW: MAKES THE SAVE.
AND RIGHT BETWEEN WOOD, HE WAS G
BLITZ TO MAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY..
AND BYS AFTER THATBACK IN